do you ever just like wake up and
remember that like toblerone like took
out like 50 percent of the [ __ ]
chocolate
i just can't believe they did that still
i still get it you know you know
toblerone yeah
yeah have you seen the modern the modern
ones no you know how the gaps used to be
very i would argue perfect you know
where the one went
up the next yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
could easily just do that right yeah
it's not like that yeah like like which
kitkats shut up
toblerones are [ __ ] massive they're
like this big i'm not gonna [ __ ]
okay i have done that
i bought too many at the airport yeah i
had i had to start you know just getting
a little wild
it's just [ __ ] deep
yeah so i think the because i was out of
the uk by this point right yeah
but uh so toblerone you know what the
toblerone looks like it looks like it
looks like this chat
not chat [ __ ] audience [ __ ] man i've
been watching too much
twitch but so i think one year they just
decided
to make less toblerones or like
they made the gaps a little bigger so
this is the original turbo yeah yeah
that's right
yeah uh you're gonna [ __ ] cross yeah
uh this is it now
yeah so that can't be real that cannot
be
real that's real yeah that is real that
is real are you [ __ ] me
yeah why are the toddler on social
distances
i don't know it's like
i just sometimes i just wake up at night
and i just remember they did that
i got away with it and they're still
like okay did they get away with it i
don't know i'm pretty sure like they
i haven't i haven't heard of recent
memory of people buying tall
i'd like to think that like even like
you know like this that this like
plummeted their stock but i don't think
it did i think sure people write it
because of this
that that's like the impression i got
even if i had known about it back in the
day i would have rioted because i i
remember it was like
it was just when i moved out the uk
because i can't remember if i was living
when did they do this
was this when you were living in the uk
so i must have just moved to thailand or
something right and i remember moving to
thailand and one day i wake up in my
time
my entire [ __ ] feed is just people
complaining about the toblerone
it's just it's like they didn't even try
and hide how much chocolate they were
taking away yeah
i just fill it with some [ __ ] make it
less tasty
like don't ruin the because one of the
best things about a toblerone
is that you get so god damn much yeah
you get a [ __ ] ton
like arguably one piece of toblerone is
too much that [ __ ] lasts you
yeah i think actually like eating a
single piece of like
the triangle is actually uncomfortable
it's almost too much it is
always the best part because good [ __ ]
too it tastes great it's the perfect
amount where you're like
i i don't even want to go for another
one i'll save it for the next day yeah
i also learned as well because i used to
always snap it like away
yeah yeah did you do that as well yeah
yeah i did that yeah but then the way i
actually do is to push it inward and it
snaps easy
oh like like that yeah you snap it in it
just breaks off
but but now you'll never get to
experience it the design is
fundamentally changed so
wait how are you supposed to snap the
new ones now i don't know [ __ ] it with a
[ __ ] knife smack it against the
concrete or something i don't know
with a knife i mean you don't need to
snap it it will probably just like
it's so it's so long that it'll probably
just break under this like strawberry
honestly yeah yeah
yeah oh my god why do they do this why
did i mask my boy like that
i i couldn't believe they did it i'm
still like wait i wake up in a cold
sweat how have i just found out about
this
i'll tell you what if it's the uk only
or not i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what i think is an
underrated snack chocolate snack terry's
chocolate orange
i [ __ ] love terry shopping do you
have chocolate orange i
don't but i've heard of it they have in
america do you have in america
yeah so it's basically just a chocolate
orange but the [ __ ]
best part of it is that it's literally
an orange that you have to like
smack and you eat
yeah it's just it's just a bowl of solid
chocolate that you eat like an orange
right and i don't know what it is like
they have like the terry's chocolate
orange bars and i don't know what it is
about playing the mini game of
like [ __ ] smacking the chocolate and
peeling it yourself it just tastes so
much better and so much more satisfying
because you're working for it
i love just smacking it against my
concrete wall in my home just [ __ ]
who wants peace i want a piece of orange
and it's always really cheap as well i'd
always go on offer for like a pound yeah
so you've got like a
way too much chocolate for really cheap
somehow it was yeah i love that wait
does it have like actual orange in it or
no no it's it's it's like a orange
chocolate flavor
right right really nice though i really
like it i don't really like orange
flavor is that exciting
because i think my aunt i think the only
reason why i know about chocolate orange
because like my aunt
like used to hand make like chocolate
orange but like actually get like slices
of orange and like
coat it in chocolate and then like
actually i've just figured out what
[ __ ] australians get patriotic about
what some reason
tim tams hell yeah
mid as [ __ ] australia [ __ ] you i think
i think the bourbon biscuits
debatable i mean it just goes to show
the quality of the rest of our snacks
right
i don't know man like i mean it's good
don't get me wrong but i'm
like tim tams or bar toblerone i'll take
the tall one
yeah to be honest like there are better
snacks out there but tim sames is just
so
readily available in australia like
anywhere you go
that's just like it's comfort food
basically yeah yeah i mean i feel like i
remember i tried it for the first time
and i feel like we have like some
very similar yeah we have really similar
stuff the uk isn't it like
penguins like kind of similar as well uh
a little bit yeah yeah yeah penguins are
great though yeah pickles are great yeah
yeah
um what else do we have in the uk oh
jaffa cakes
no jeff cakes yeah what do you think
about jaffa cakes i'm pretty sure
okay good good that sounds familiar
sponge cake with uh
like orange juice yeah yeah
we have those in australia too yeah yeah
yeah they're all right
they have horrible shelf life those
things go bad really fast
yeah and like you know the only time i
ever ate them was at my grandma's place
it's it the packet is big enough why you
like you kind of have to do it in one
setting because they
again yeah you open the bag they go bad
in one day yeah so
like if you buy them for yourself you
got to commit to eating it's definitely
like a
home party snack whenever you go to any
gathering
or any kind of like eat like a camping
trip or something everyone always brings
out the jaffa cakes and i never
understood why
because it's the middle snack in england
in my opinion
and for some reason people think they
want people people think i want a piece
of that
you know you want it i like the taste of
it i think it's nice but after i have
two i'm like you know what
i'm good for the next five years i'm
fine
like i enjoy it though i mean that's how
i feel about kinder eggs
oh i [ __ ] love kinder eggs that's
great but i have like two
and i'm like this is so much sugar i'm
i'm not about what kenda bueno balls are
amazing
kendall what kinder boy oh this is great
it's really [ __ ] good like kinder
eggs and a black hazelnut as well yeah
the hazelnut ones are amazing
um i'll bring you some when i when i go
home